Neal Payne senior writer for 538
previously wrote for ESPN and the New
York Times consulted with the for the
NBA's Atlanta Hawks and the latest
article I saw this yesterday and it said
MLB owners say they could lose four
billion dollars even if games are played
does the math add up I'm not good at
math but Neal is and he joins us now
does the math add up there Neal well
first of all thanks for having me on Dan
and based on my calculations it really
doesn't and it's tough to find a way for
it to add up to that four billion dollar
loss so what I did was I looked at these
estimates that you've probably seen
these every year Forbes puts out for the
amount of money that teams make how they
make it so you know gate receipts but
also other sources of revenue and then
how much they spend and the big bulk of
that is on players and I tried to
itemize each of the ways that they make
money and try to figure out how much of
that would be lost if they had to play
games without fans if they had to play
fewer games and so on and so forth so
right off the bat the league makes about
forty to forty five percent of its
revenue from just fans coming into games
and not just ticket sales but also
concessions and parking and all of the
things around coming to a game that's
all at the window but that's still in a
full season leaves you with about five
billion dollars to work with of which
varying amounts will still be almost
totally guaranteed when we're talking
about TV money even if you play without
fans or even have a shortened season so
when you do the math on it it starts to
kind of look like these claims of a four
billion loss don't make that much sense
are the owners lying a little or a lot
here new I think they so I don't want to
accuse them of lying because I think
that there are other people have hinted
at this even Scott Boras is one of them
have hinted at the the loans and the
debt that these owners take on with the
assumption that teams will appreciate in
value and be able to generate
ever-escalating revenue they've broken
the revenue record who knows how many
straight years including last year so
you know there are two ways
look at it there there's a way to look
at it as self-contained playing baseball
money from playing baseball versus how
much you're paying the players and other
employees do you make a profit and in
that case I think they are not telling
the truth when it comes to that but when
you take into account these other things
that they may well come out behind on
that in the short term but the big
question is should the players be made
to take cuts to their salary to
subsidize these investments that the
owners didn't have to make they chose to
make or take out these loans and the
owners are getting equity out of this
whereas the players don't get anything
in exchange they don't get interest on
the the money that they're deferring
potentially to allow the owners to see
fit to play games if I made you the
arbitrator how would you bring both
sides together yeah I mean I would come
to a compromise it seems like the the
players want to play more games because
for them especially if they get paid on
a per game basis they get paid more
money it makes sense the owners want to
play fewer games because really they're
not making the money from having fans in
the stands already so they don't care to
a certain extent because their TV
revenue is largely guaranteed especially
if the playoffs are played their main
focus is getting the playoffs in it
would be a catastrophic situation if for
whatever reason because of the virus
there were no playoffs then you'd start
to talk about that money to have to give
up so I would come to a compromise where
you know the players want a 100 game
season the the owners seem to want it to
be pushed down to maybe 50 games it
seems like a 75 game season where the
players give up you know maybe they're
not paid 50 percent of their money off
of that of what they would expect but
not to ask them to go all the way down
to 24 percent which was one of the
proposals where they were talking about
paying Mike Trout you know five million
dollars compared with his usual salary
for a half a season worth of games and
they're still even now trying to get
them down to 31 percent so it seems like
some compromise where you let the owners
you know allow them to play fewer games
but pay them roughly their usual salary
or more of their per game salary and if
you
after the first salary into the future
do that but also work out a deal to
maybe have interest associated with that
maybe an escrow account how many owners
do you think if you're looking in the
financial aspect of this that don't want
this season to come back because that's
been floated out there whether it's true
or not and I didn't know if that's a
bargaining chip here yeah I mean there
are probably a few owners that didn't
make money last year and if you look at
you know the Forbes numbers they talk
about the Baltimore Orioles are in there
the Toronto Blue Jays are in there the
Marlins are in there and and I don't
think it's a coincidence that the
Orioles and the Marlins actually didn't
have much revenue coming from gate
receipts because they built deliberately
terrible teams and also you know sort of
cut down their salaries
what about Oakland the Oakland A's feel
like that's a tenuous situation yeah and
even according to the public estimates
even the Oakland A's made money last
year in terms of net operating income
and again that is before some of these
loans and some of the other financial
situation from the owners come into play
so I don't doubt that when you look at
that in the equation you might find
owners that are like look it's probably
not worth it or at the very least we're
not gonna make the the appreciation of
our team that we would expect in a
normal year which was the basis for
investing in this team to begin with but
you know they have to understand that
that you know even in a major league
baseball team ownership situation making
a profit especially a large profit or a
record-breaking profit every year is not
guaranteed and and there are sort of
bigger things at play than than just
whether or not one season would find
them in the red I'll leave you with this
what do you think the chances are that
we still have what we consider a
so-called baseball season I think
they're high I mean I don't know what
what you would consider so-called
because I think if there is like a 50
game season it's gonna be very
interesting in terms of the types of
seasons guys have some people will
probably hit maybe hit 400 they see that
and also you know will the winner have
an asterisk attached to their name more
so than maybe some teams we've seen
recently like the
for a different reason but I think in
terms of the odds of them actually
having any kind of season they're still
very high because most of the owners
have too much to lose to not play and
the players certainly have too much to
lose to not play there's just too much
of a financial interest and that's
before you get into the larger issue of
what baseball's future could look like
if they go you know with the optics of
them haggling over money in the middle
of a pandemic and a recession if they
decide not to play a game when they had
the option to do so Neil thanks for
joining us I enjoyed the deep dive on
538 we appreciate your time thank you
for having me it's it's a real pleasure
it's a neil ping a senior writer for 538
used to write for ESPN Insider